the government is rolling out sweeping
new guidelines and ramping up oversight
of organic food the agriculture
Department says the first of its kind
changes will help Stamp Out fraud and
protect organic Integrity throughout the
supply chain Nikki Batiste has more
organic foods are everywhere but now the
USDA is cracking down with new rules
that will make it harder to claim that
organic label this is the single largest
revision to the organic standards since
they've been published initially in 2000
the USDA will strengthen enforcement of
its current guidelines that organic
products must be produced without toxic
pesticides synthetic nitrogen
fertilizers antibiotics hormones or
genetic engineering the new regulations
will require certification for all
imported organic foods inspections will
increase and businesses will need to
prove all parts of their supply chain
are organic but organic is created at a
farm it needs to be maintained through a
supply chain Tom Chapman says the
stricter guidelines will give Shoppers
confidence their products are certified
organic it streamlines the authority of
the USDA to bring enforcement actions
against anyone who's doing anything
fraudulent Nationwide sales of organic
foods more than doubled over the past 10
years in 2020 sales soared to nearly 62
billion is there any way for Shoppers to
know what is truly organic in the store
yes them you look for that uh USA
organic seal that's your vote of
confidence that this product is truly
organic the new
wrecked in March and companies have a
year to meet the new requirements if you
only have money in your budget to buy
some organic food nutritionists
recommend prioritizing organic fruits
and vegetables for CBS Saturday morning
Nikki Batiste Cross River New York
are we allowed to say about time yeah we
had the labels we've been talking about
it seems like people have been talking
to us for a long long time yeah you want
to know what you're eating is what
you're eating yeah you are watching that
there I want to know who I am
that's a longer conversation yes it is